[Music]
[Music]
today we're gonna focus on the exchange
sacrifice who here knows what an
exchange sacrifice is so-so yeah you
said it's when you sacrifice a piece of
greater value for one of for one of us
or value to get usually some sort of
positional advantage but not necessarily
a positional advantage sometimes it's a
tactical or an attacking edge that
you're gonna get okay so for you guys up
front black to move what's a good move
here you brookie a hmm
Oh rook just taking right here on e3 so
you can promote you don't care about
giving up the giving up the exchange
right good yeah I like how you found
that really fast so it's just a really
simple example of what wouldn't exchange
sacrifices this is one that was
definitely yeah that's definitely
tactical in nature let's take a look at
another tactical one there you guys know
the theme it's easy to find right yeah
how about you rook takes e4 and then
when I take back with the Brooke what
are you gonna play then yeah so your
friend back there you had the idea but
sometimes we've just got to get the move
order that it happens all the time it's
actually more yeah more often than not
you're gonna get the idea but not the
way to make it work so yeah Bishop f3 is
the move you want to play but only after
sacrificing the exchange on e4 to create
the tactical opportunity for the skewer
like like you're mentioning up front
exactly
you guys ready to look at a game alright
yeah Spassky versus Petrosyan so this is
a game that was played in the World
Championship in 1966 this is it this is
the match that petrosyan won in the
second match that they played three
years later Spassky won this is Game
seven from the first match
Petrosyan has black Spassky has white
and I think he did this a few times in
both of their World Championship matches
Spassky is an e4 player but tried to
employ a little psychological tactic and
you play d4 against against a big d4
player what's that potentially you could
be a Kings Indian on you tell me though
is that a king's indian move no very
good yeah you can still transpose play
c4 in the e4 and do all the king's
Indian stuff there's a little bit
there's a little bit of a quieter idea I
bet you can kennel recognize it over
there you six still pretty flexible nope
nope what why what's the problem with
playing e3 immediately so then yeah
would you which is your thing but this
is like Kali asking as much as it's a
you know low ambition low theory d4 yeah
just like yeah what's the other one he
had the Kali and the London on Tori
or just Queens pawn is how this usually
gets categorized Bishop g5 yeah and if
you do Bishop do you you've seen Bishop
g5 without Knight f3 first I have what
do we call that that's the Tron passkey
yeah that's the Chun Taos game this
one's this one's Vettori when Knight f3
gets played first um quiet definitely
not the aggressive chest that a lot of
you guys have seen and some of these
other lectures where it's a four a five
and just a brutal King side attack
there's a quieter game and we're gonna
learn about stuff other than attacking
chest tonight so hopefully you guys will
walk away with that okay so night BD to
just develop in pieces often with the
idea of getting this night getting the
knight on f3 to e5 and then this guy
will so
a swing to f3 to back him up that's
usually got the idea behind that behind
that a queenside night development
breaking the pin playing III but just
just two moves after you wanted it well
yeah he'll equalize right and what's the
advantage of white is that you have the
first move so you can always be ahead
and development if you pay enough
attention to it right yep you give up
the initiative which more or less means
you let your opponent kind of go about
on his own plans unhindered okay the
trophy makes a similar move what are his
ideas here do you guys think
c5 yeah keeping it moving yes sir c5 is
the idea which is why he plays it there
oh I see she called it in the back got a
positional positional Pro back there yes
sir sorry David put the spotlight on you
there okay high-five exactly so c5
gaining space on the Queen side
achieving a strategic break on when you
get you guys when you play this kind of
structure with black this is a move that
you always want to try and get in you
know at the earliest point possible who
plays the French defense Jason Jason
plays it anybody else nope
too boring too slow for the Rings for
the for the rest of you guys I play the
French defense yeah anyway point being
when you have this e 65 chain c5 is a
good maneuver to gain space and peace
activity just ending getting into a
Canwest esque type position right with
this little triangle okay
clever clever move obvious with the
obvious developments idea of developing
his minor piece which minor piece the
bishop right but what would you play I
I'd be surprised if any of you guys
would want to play b6 there what would
you play here ya [ __ ] so all the
grandmasters watching the game and the
ones who wrote about it after everyone
well maybe not everyone gives next X
clam to this move but they all
appreciate the fact that he delayed
castling here because he doesn't want
this night to he doesn't mind the night
coming in here unless he's Castle
kingside once he's Castle kingside then
say we Castle here instead of instead of
playing b6 well then this this gets
annoying doesn't it yeah it's gonna kick
that night away he's gonna maybe even be
able to get his Queen to d2 he might be
able to castle long and get some sort of
killer and annoying attack on the black
Kings side so petrosyan wisely leaves
his options open instead just defend the
c5 pawn again more importantly gets
ready to develop his LightSquared bishop
okay he's enthusiastic over there all
right that's cool it yeah I can learn
something from that okay
get energized okay so the knight gets to
e5 but he's not worried about it
why not who do you guys like here let's
get some evaluations yeah let's start
with orange jacket huh what did you what
do you think here
excellent so that advanced pawn mmm
weakness or strength
d5 yeah weakness
it certainly is exerting some power on
the dark squares in black's camp namely
d6 and f6
that being said I think I agree with you
back there not really worth it how about
you Liam it's not about right or what
else did what are you thinking sounds
good huh
okay so for that reason he'd be happy
black would be happy to trade those
bishops all right
he was definitely probably thinking
about King safety so even though he saw
this g5 line you just played Queen c7
focusing another piece on e5 but more
importantly getting ready to Castle yeah
getting ready to Castle queenside okay
tonight at 3 because if anything silly
like queen g4 attacking the g7 pawn then
you can just play an immediate g5 and
get a scary get the G file open and
looking really scary against the white
King this task you didn't go in for that
plays Knight f3 just defending e5 what
do you guys think is best here for black
yeah g5 on probably playable mmm but you
are you are sacking it yeah you make me
second-guess myself you're you but still
I mean in these other lines we're
looking at we're sacrificing that pawn
anyway uh probably okay to play g5 here
Oh f6 you say f6 look looks a little
scary and I and I wouldn't want to
contend with with the week with
weakening my light squares like that
with his LightSquared bishop still on
the board what's that mm-hmm
g5 immediately is caught
probably losing a pond um we could look
at it with the engine that they're you
know really maybe losing a pond but once
that G file is even half open against
the king like that sometimes it's worth
it
way more than worth it place it a little
little safe though it just plays h6 no
need to rush no need to rush here keeps
it flexible and Spassky lashes out is
this losing a pawn for him
to sacrifice and if he goes for it
what's the point of all sacrifices and
gambits
what's one of the main points what well
to get files open rapid development on
peace activity is another way of framing
that but exactly yeah
why didn't we gambit to develop rapidly
and we sacrifice stuff to get peace
activity look at all those arrows okay
anyway it's kind of a dry game I wrote
not a lot of explosive tactics I've
already been I've been called out for
not being the most energetic presenter
of games so throwing some surprise
arrows there all right if only I could
remember what they mean 94
okay so yeah the idea here is
illustrating you know the the plans for
for white why he would want to sack that
pawn I cuz he's gonna get the C file
open like you mentioned over there for
his rook this rook is gonna get to see
one the Queen's going to come out to
either g4 or h5 and the bishop ideally
will retreat after h3 has been played on
and we'll be able to get f4 in and and
look alright so did we take the pawn
with black give them all that activity
no right no we don't you go on with our
own attack because our attack is looking
good already
what do we play here anybody huh age
five nice yeah with the threat of age
for winning the bishop here you really
he reacts with H for H three is also
playable but it gets a little tricky he
plays H for it was black what do you got
what have we been talking about yeah
wuji for mmm okay yeah what to get the G
file open yes sir yeah that's right stay
away claim a buy-in alive yeah if you're
facing in your ferret against n right
okay GH do we take it even though we're
attacking it twice and it's only
defended once why not you're on fire man
yeah you're on fire all right nice
exactly
I do remember what that highlights for
that's illustrating that he v is his
priority he does not want to oh you know
he doesn't want to capture on h4 okay
finally we get our our exclam deserving
long castles castles long all right what
is he telling him every some of you guys
saw me cover the tall game that we
didn't put on YouTube but same deal here
he's committing to attack on which side
yes sir
mmm-hmm King side yes yes take Kings
side right and his Queen his King
ideally we'll be safe over here on the
on the Queen side and if need be he'll
get off the off the C file and scoot
over
and here we have a four plate and this
is just get some pretty harsh criticism
because what will you guys play with
black here how do we continue to clamp
down on the light squares I've heard it
out here well isn't it was the other
idea a six he said mm-hmm f6 okay that
might be a little off track because he
can recapture with a discovered attack
maybe but we are looking for pawn breaks
or we at least want to debate the merits
and demerits of capturing or pushing but
yeah we I heard the answer out there at
c4 we clamp down we just push push
forward here and again a bunch of crazy
arrows what do they mean what do they
mean
what Square are we giving up control of
when we play C 5 c4 okay hence the green
does it really matter what if that
Knight goes there you undefended the
pawn with all with all the scary red
arrows pointing at it the maneuver that
I have diagrammed here yes bishop f8 to
B 2 g8 g7 attacking e5 right
silly asked to move the bishop it was
funny there's a lot of you know
interesting analysis I'm given by
Petrosyan on this game and one thing
that he claims that was seriously
considered was this move yeah I was yeah
you're interesting right okay why yeah
you win the night with its yeah you need
to still not I mean black is still okay
if I remember right I think the engine
just said something like this and
there's a man they're not as good well
said yeah they're looking pretty sorry
here um yeah I I'm I I think he is still
fine but it with precise play that night
is gonna get to d4 and you're never it's
gonna be really hard to get rid of them
yeah I agree yeah just something like
this thinking yet depending on what
white does right so yeah I mean there's
a lot of there are a lot of irritating
things to worry about here uh so he we
understand well but but one of the
points is that he's not obligated to
take though on f5 uh uh and if he
doesn't then Spassky allegedly didn't
like the idea of the bishop on h3 biting
on granite against the the stone wall of
black pawns on the lot on the light
squares so that being said
he retreats him to e to instead of going
in for that interesting looking tactical
tribe Bishop f5 and this is another ex
clan move big ex clam is awarded to
petrosyan for this why and I you know
seriously this is the kind of thing that
I need spelled out to me but make sense
lit it's no crazy tactical reason he's
just doing what he's famous for he's
famous for a few for mm-hmm exchange
sacrifice is very good Wow just
historian - yeah which is what we're
gonna see here that is the point of this
game that's what I'm claiming at least
but a lot of rich positional themes to
get get through beforehand and this is
one of them stopping counter play cues
you know just like Karpov he gets
compared to like anacondas and
constrictors because they just squeeze
the life out of their opponents position
and Asics kind of does that it's it
prevents any hopes of counter play on
the queenside which is why you don't
Petrosyan wisely items I'm sorry Spassky
with white pieces wisely does not
doesn't play b5 or a5 or anything like
that um he first worries about King
safety gets his King off the scary
semi-open file
Petrosyan puts his rook on the scary
semi-open defends and there we go
what's that talk to me yeah I can't hear
you
I see oh you saw this game okay well
dazzle us that because I think it only
gets more interesting from here that I
had a lot of fun going over this one for
this okay so rook g4 all right potential
exchange sacrifice I think everyone here
this is why would why would we be okay
with with exchanging that
exchanging the the rook for a minor
piece on g4 why might we mmm structure
what about what's bad with blacks pawn
structure he is yeah this guy right no
what do you what do you yeah but didn't
yeah what in blacks position is is bad
so and you Evie what you have to say
anything yeah so this is a weakness
compensated for by our attacking chances
but we would be okay with exchanging on
g4 because it would eliminate that
weakness we could under those pawns and
maybe we'll see that happen well see so
Queen d2 finally connecting the rooks
doubling up on that weak looking G file
trying desperately trying to get some
peace activity yes sir
b5 locking it up now he's forced to play
on on the on the kingside white was
forced to play on the Kings side so we
get rook a d1 again just praying for
activity and Bishop f8 we've been
playing close attention what's the idea
behind Bishop that faith Bishop g7
trying to just corral that weak pawn
right so one thing I really like about
the these kinds of games is that they're
not one not at first at least and not
before move you know 25 on with wild
explosive tactical combos it's a lot of
quiet play just slowly slowly uh
attacking our opponents weaknesses in
this case C 5 and
the other weaknesses he's created so 9h
- are we worried about that what do you
say I see a hand raised what are you
gonna move oh excuse me yeah what do you
think here what what what should we play
for black its corral that weakness he
just son defended it right with this
move we're not worried about this as we
already said we're gonna we're just
going to recapture what seems bad
tactically right why what do we just
self self taint mmm one thing is that
gyms are pretty good at calculating all
right from what I understand and he
knows that there's no way for white to
exploit that pin
he has no pawn on the e-file with which
to attack the pin knight on e5 a second
time right and the bishops on the FI
also it's kind of a moot point um and he
can just play Bishop d6 yeah and one
thing we just kind of glossed over
efore again just a desperate attempt at
getting activity and it's a little trap
e2 what happens if we take what happens
if we take is there a trap for white
uh-huh what do ya say it out right after
your right Bishop takes e5 with what
idea the Queen yeah with winning a piece
at least right yeah or not if not just
meeting him
right like this yeah so thankfully this
game would not be as interesting if it
ended that way right it goes on like
this he finally gets the dark squared
Bishop Soph the board he's looking okay
hoping hoping against hope that he's
going to be able to play de and increase
pressure on g4 what do you play with
black here which move g3 yeah pressing
you guys want to press on but he five is
it's nice and that's what Petrosyan
played nice and now the really hard move
which I'm not going to torture you guys
trying to find f5 it's smashing away at
that at e4 pawn right a lot of people
think EF might have been a better try do
we retake here or do we use our huge
pawn majority on the King site to do
some real damage
I like the way you're thinking what are
we saying back there nothing I buy any
ideas well what would you guys play up
here how about you all again yeah push
the pawns okay well I'm gonna go with
the answer I heard from the bet from the
back f4 attacking the Queen and after
she after she goes to d5 what are you
gonna play she goes - I'm sorry - e4
what are you gonna play yes sir
everyone agree that everyone agree right
keep you keep him out of the center
again just trying to do something about
this alarming looking pawn mass which is
push mmm what have we wanted to bring it
what do I said bring another piece into
the attack first
yeah nice good job you're on fire two
sharp analysts in the room tonight okay
Bishop c8 sensible retreat now you get
your g3 move on the board rook e1 saying
h3 nice mm-hmm
let's increase pressure a little bit so
let's build the pressure because mm-hmm
okay Jade you're probably okay taking on
G to it this just poses way more
problems for him um way more getting out
of the discovery getting the getting
another pair of miners off the board now
the killer
efore row gauge one I mean yeah these
but it's I'm just like catching myself
he's not stacking anything but he
obviously can't take because he four is
defended and you have to contend with
this is what you're talking about right
so he tries to get bring another
LightSquared defender in now what was
petrosyan x' killer tactical blow and
there are two stray stronger engine
variations but you know his still rates
as crushing it's like 12 12 point
advantage or something but they
gave you like a I think there's like did
like a forced matin 10 or 11 maybe from
here what's your move
III okay what else
let's hear some other ones Queen d7 and
Queen e5 are the two computer lines on
Queen d7 with the idea of getting in his
face and Queen e5 there's uh there's
some force made threats but we're
running low on time so I'm gonna blow
everybody's mind here with Nagi for why
would he play that yes sir
and then what just push the pawn dead in
the water
yep just desperado as Denis burrows says
just a good song from the Eagles right
yeah okay I'm on fire tonight
all right I hope you guys enjoyed that
hit like share subscribe see you guys
next time okay thank you
[Music]
you